[APPLAUSE]
ANDERS SANDHOLM: Thanks, Bob.
Thanks, Kevin.
KASPER LUND: Thank
you very much.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, thanks.
ANDERS SANDHOLM: It's
great to be here in Munich.
Great to see all of you here.
As was just said, I'm
here with Dan and Kasper,
and we're really
excited to be here.
I think I speak for all of us,
maybe after the third rewrite
of the entire slide
deck yesterday evening,
we're a little bit too excited.
But hopefully things
will be just fine.
As was just mentioned, this
is actually the second Dart
Summit.
So last year we were
in San Francisco.
A little over 150 people there.
Just maybe a show
of hands, anyone who
was there with us last year.
Yeah, a few familiar faces.
Really, really cool
to see you again.
And great to see so many
new people here as well.
We're in Munich, we actually
have close to 300 people
who registered for the event,
so great to see that momentum as
well.
And obviously where
we will be next year.
Hopefully it'll be even more and
hope to see all of you again.
KASPER LUND: On
a boat somewhere.
ANDERS SANDHOLM: Yeah, who
knows where we'll end up.
But actually, before moving
on to some of the great news
that we're going
to share with you.
I want to-- I have a confession.
I want to be honest with you.
If we take a step back and
look at where we were a little
over a year ago when we met
for the summit last time.
This was right after we
had announced the shift
in strategy, where we moved
away from the focus of having
the Dart view in Chrome to
having Dart for the entire web.
So having the ability
to use all modern
browsers not just for deployment
but also for development.
And you could say in some
sense for some people,
maybe it's been somewhat quiet
in terms of news from our side.
Even at the time it
might feel like a setback
in some sense for some
people, especially
if you were looking at
some of the encouragement
we were getting on
social media around this.
[LAUGHTER]
But to tell you
the actual story,
is that while maybe on the news
side we've been somewhat quiet.
Actually we've been
really, really busy.
So what the shift in
strategy allowed us to do
was to do a lot of work
with our key customers.
Understanding their
use of Dart and help
them expand their usage.
We had over 10,000
commits just on the core
SDK since that announcement.
And so that's really
allowed us to understand
better what the issues
were for our key customers.
Help them solve
them and really have
Dart be a much more
productive web stack for them.
And that helps us end
up where we are today.
Celebrating over the next
few days, a lot of this news
and in particular Dart
is in all kinds of ways
very much an open
source project.
It is also, for Google,
very serious business.
So just for one
of our customers,
there's more than $70 billion
of revenue flowing through Dart
software every year.
That Dart is the tech stack
of choice for Google Ads.
But we're not just seeing
serious use of this.
This is also-- if the
revenue number isn't enough,
these are not toy apps,
we're talking about millions
of lines of code.
And we're seeing a
tremendous amount
of momentum inside of Google
just over the past year.
We've seen the amount of
Dart code more than triple.
And this actually makes Dart,
I'm very happy to say this,
is the fastest growing
language inside Google.
We're growing from a
smaller base admittedly,
but still this is
really fantastic.
You know, why are we
seeing this momentum?
I think one of the key themes
that we see when talking teams,
is that they get
better velocity.
We've seen increased
productivity.
Some teams have reported twice
the productivity of what they
had with their previous stack.
KASPER LUND: That's
really significant.
2x productivity, that
really makes a difference
for any kind of team size.
DAN GROVE: Absolutely.
ANDERS SANDHOLM: Definitely.
And so what allowed
us to get here
was really this
change in strategy.
And working really closely
with our key customers
in striving for Dart to
become the most productive web
stack for them.
And who would be better to
talk about this than you, Dan,
you work quite closely
with a lot of these teams.
DAN GROVE: I did.
So, who here can
identify the products
that these logos represent?
Totally obvious, right.
The upper one is
AdWords for Google.
Kind of a big product.
This is AdSense down here,
this yellow and is that purple.
Not sure.
KASPER LUND: Blueish.
DAN GROVE: Greentea is our
customer relationship app.
Google Fiber's logo actually
tells you what they do,
so that one's kind of easy.
All of these are all Dart.
So it's really amazing to see
how much real stuff is being
built on Dart at this point.
Let's take a step
back in time though.
Around the time at
the summit last year
we saw this note from one
of our VPs of engineering.
This is a guy who runs, he
has like 1,000-ish people,
1,000 engineers working for him.
And he was excited.
And I was really happy
that he was excited,
because if I had rolled
back time a little bit
further, six months earlier,
I'd been on vacation.
And I got back
from vacation and I
noticed I had a calendar
appointment from him
for the moment I
arrived in the office.
It's like, that is not good.
[LAUGHTER]
You do not want to
have someone who's
managing 1,000 people drop an
appointment on your calendar
for the day you get back from
vacation, at 8:00 o'clock
in the morning.
Right?
Never a good sign.
We had a little discussion
of areas that were hurting.
And there were some
things happening
that were hurting productivity.
And we spend a lot of time
listening to those people.
And Scott got very happy.
And the ads engineering
team got extremely happy.
So what did we learn
while we were listening?
We learned that we had
done a couple of things.
We had a really nice language.
So we had a language
that was kind
of walking this tightrope
between being familiar,
being modern.
We have all kinds of
nice, cool features.
Things like cascades,
async await.
You have a terse language.
This is something people
really like if they're
coming from the Java world.
What we hear from
Java developers
is that they're
often writing a third
to a half the number of lines
of code when they move to Dart.
KASPER LUND: It's very
consistent feedback we get.
I think the terseness
really works well.
I think most people
here probably feel
that when they write Dart
code, that having a terse,
a flexible, nice to use
language is really key.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, I mean
there's a balance, right.
Like APL was terse
too, but I don't know
that it was highly productive.
I think we're actually
at a pretty good spot.
And it's really scalable.
The teams that I
talked to about it
have dozens of core engineers
and often hundreds of people
contributing to their
projects, and contributing
from around the world.
So you have to build a
system that really scales.
And yet we want something that
is still flexible and fun.
And I think most people are
enjoying doing programming
in Dart, and that's
what you guys are here.
We feel pretty confident
that we've actually
reached a really nice balance.
And I think we see a similar
balance in the core libraries.
There are bunch of
different approaches
you can take to core libraries.
You can go the JavaScript
route and not really have any.
You can go the Java route and
have very, very large core
libraries.
We tried to reach a middle
point and build something that
was tight and comprehensive.
And I think we wound up
in a pretty good spot.
We also spent a lot of
time making them coherent,
and that was really nice.
So things like
streams are pervasive
and really work well
across the libraries.
ANDERS SANDHOLM:
You know, I think
that especially with the
coherency, when we introduced
async await last year, it
turned out that worked really
well with the existing
streams in the core libraries,
it's where coherency
really paid off.
DAN GROVE: And
overall, the libraries
are nice and efficient
so people are actually
getting good performance
out of these things.
But when we listen
further, what we learned
was that this wasn't
actually enough.
Yes, we had a nice language,
we had nice core libraries,
but were they actually
useful for web developers.
Maybe this is why Scott
set up a meeting with me.
Something along these lines.
KASPER LUND: This is
not Scott by the way.
DAN GROVE: That's not Scott.
So one of the questions that
we heard from our users was,
how can I use JS libraries?
Our first answer was, no.
[LAUGHTER]
And that wound up
not actually being
the answer that a lot of
people wanted to hear.
KASPER LUND: It
was short though.
DAN GROVE: It was terse.
[LAUGHTER]
But not really flexible or fun.
So we built a new,
improved JS interop.
One thing that's really nice is
that by waiting a little bit,
the JavaScript community
started learning about types,
and they started building
these things called
TypeScript definition files,
and putting those out on the web
so that you actually had
types available for JavaScript
libraries.
So with our new
JS interop system,
you can convert TypeScript
definition files to start .Dart
files automatically.
And this is fantastic,
because once you
do that, you get all the
benefits of IntelliJ, the Dart
Analyzer, you can just use
that thing as if it's Dart.
And we're launching
this later today.
So, Jacob Richmond will be
giving a talk on JS interop
sometime today.
I don't remember the schedule.
You should come to that.
And the rest of the talks.
Another question that
we got a lot was,
how do I develop
outside Dartium?
And this could be
as simple as, I'm
building an app for my
Android phone using Chrome.
We don't have
Dartium on Android.
Or I want to use
another browser, right?
There are other
browsers out there.
KASPER LUND: For a
long time our answer
to that question was
like, use Dart to JS.
But I worked on Dart
to JS for a while,
and it's a really good tool,
but it's not super fast.
So if you have that in
your development workflow,
it's going to slow you down.
So we needed something better.
DAN GROVE: It especially
slows you down
if you're building a big app.
We have teams that Google
for whom Dart to JS
takes several
minutes to compile,
and that doesn't fit the fun
box that we checked off earlier.
So we built this thing
called the Dart Dev Compiler,
and this is really super.
So one of the nice
things it does,
is it does modular compilation.
So how many of you
have used Dart to JS?
Lots of people.
Produces essentially one
giant JS file, or maybe a few
if you're doing
deferred loading.
What we do with the dev
compiler, is instead,
we compile library by library.
So the idea is that if
your application is made up
of a hundred libraries,
you'll have 100 JS files
and you'll only recompile
the ones that are necessary.
This makes it much, much faster.
Another thing that's
fantastic, Chrome
started building extension
points in DevTools.
So if you're used to
the Dartium devtools,
we can actually provide you
with all those features,
even with the Dart Dev
Compiler in Chrome.
And the way this came
about was pretty funny.
One of our team members had
worked on another compilation
to JS project several years ago,
and worked with the Chrome team
to get these
extension points in.
He left that team and
then came to our team
and then we realized
that we needed this.
And at that point the
stuff landed in Chrome.
And so we were able to use it.
It's really a nice experience.
So all those cool Dartium
things, like a ripple,
you can do all of that
with the dev compiler.
Browsers were also catching
up here with some nice ES 6
support, and that lets us
put out much nicer JavaScript
in the dev compiler.
And all this adds
up to give you fast,
nice cross browser support
which we're working on today.
So right now you can
use Chrome for this,
you don't need to use Dartium.
So you don't need to wait for
us to get Dartium up to date,
which is often challenging.
You just use the regular
Chrome on your desktop.
We're also working
on Safari right now,
and we will be working
on Firefox and Edge
in the near future.
And the amazing
thing about this,
is that with the dev compiler,
you can get fast edit refresh
at real scale.
So we're talking
100,000 lines of code,
typical refresh is going to
be under a second with the dev
compiler.
So, no more need for
Dartium with dev compiler,
and you can get a really
beautiful, fast edit
refresh cycle.
KASPER LUND: Very slick.
DAN GROVE: There's
other stuff that
needed to happen to improve
the dev cycle, though.
Transformers were an area
that was kind of painful.
Anyone who's used these will
probably recognize this.
Things like not putting
the artifacts that
were created on disk,
made it kind of hard
to see what was happening.
We're replacing this with
a code generation system
that actually will put
artifacts on disk so you
can go read them, play
with them, mess with them,
see what you did wrong.
Faster static
analysis was something
where we did a bunch of
changes to the Dart analyzer.
Part of this was in support
of the Dart dev compiler.
And the end result here, is
that the analyzer can basically
operate on summaries,
which are essentially
module by module summarization's
of your application.
So rather than having to
look at the whole application
monolithically, the
analyzer can only
look at things
that have changed.
One of my favorite
things, and many people
think is a tiny thing, but
getting formatting right.
[APPLAUSE]
KASPER LUND: That
was very popular.
DAN GROVE: It's really
irritating, right,
to send out a code review and
have people tell you that you
formatted things wrong.
What do they know?
KASPER LUND: My
formatting is the best.
DAN GROVE: Right.
So we decide to
solve this and we
let Bob define how things
would get formatted.
And actually this is
working out great,
because it eliminates a huge
set of issues in code reviews.
And the thing is
that people love
picking on formatting
in code reviews, right.
Because it's really easy.
You just get to
go needle someone,
you don't have to
actually think about it.
Just move this around.
We get rid of this.
It's fantastic.
And finally we've done a
lot of work with Jet Brains
to make IntelliJ much better.
And one thing that
is fantastic is
that this gives us a
great story for both
our web and our mobile story.
So IntelliJ is becoming a really
key piece of our development
cycle.
There were other
questions though.
When we started talking
about building things
like AdWords in Dart.
We got lots of questions
from teams about scalability.
We had never built
something this large before.
KASPER LUND: It
was somewhat bigger
than what we started with.
And so these are really,
really significant apps
and they grow
really quickly, too.
DAN GROVE: Exactly.
So one of the
things that we found
was that we really needed a
solid and trustworthy type
system to enable scalability.
And we also needed a fast
and modular build system.
And so we have been working on
both of these over the past two
years or so.
So one of the things we
found was that stronger types
scale better.
So it's no secret,
that within Google, we
develop all of our source
code, that's for internal use,
inside one gigantic tree.
And if you want to be able to
do things like refactoring,
you have to be able to
do refactoring across, oh
all the code that
Google's ever written.
I mean it's kind of a
large amount of code.
And that was very difficult to
do with the original Dart type
system.
Because the type system, it
was kind of squishy, right.
And so we developed
a strong mode.
And the key points with
strong mode-- and Leaf
will be talking about
this later today--
are that type errors
actually matter.
So in Dart one, type
errors were type warnings.
You could keep running,
it was no problem.
In strong mode, type errors
actually matter, period.
We also use type inference.
The idea is that it should
be obvious to all tools,
that if you say something like,
var x equals a string, that x
is actually a string.
And this is something that's
pretty intuitive to users,
but it's something-- I
think many people thought
Dart was operating this way,
because we're kind of tricky.
But it wasn't really, and now
with strong mode it will be.
The other thing that's
important for this,
is that we're adding
generic methods to Dart.
And the reason for
this is pretty obvious.
If you actually
care about types,
which you do in
strong mode, you don't
want to be dropping those
types on the floor every time
you're passing
through a generic.
ANDERS SANDHOLM:
And I think that you
mentioned introducing
strong mode as a way
to better scale your code.
I think it also serves
another purpose.
From you talking
to external teams,
I talk with Soundtrap, a Swedish
startup, long term Dart user
a few weeks back, and got
really positive feedback.
They found out about strong
mode, started using it,
and just getting the
error messages early on
was just a huge benefit
for them as well.
Kim mentioned this is as well,
he's giving a talk tomorrow.
I've also had a very good
experience trying out
strong mode.
DAN GROVE: Yeah, it's
kind of like people
would rather find out about
errors at development time,
than when they deploy things.
But you know, it's just an idea.
Another question that
we heard a lot was, OK,
you've got all this cool
stuff, but my job is basically
building web
applications, and I need
to be able to build
really nice UIs,
and I need to be able
to build them fast.
So when we started off, we said,
oh well you have dart:html.
I mean, some people like that.
It's a kind of nice
library, but it's not
really enough to make
people super happy.
At least most people.
And we did a couple
of iterations
here as we tried to
hone in on what we
thought the right answer was.
So we did a lot of
work with Polymer.
Probably some of you have
experimented with that.
And we were wrapping
a JS library,
we weren't thrilled with it.
We started working
with the Angular team
and came up with something that
felt pretty nice to program
with Angular 1.
But it also didn't have the
performance that we wanted,
and it didn't have
that Darty feel.
It was using mirrors.
It was something that wasn't
quite what we wanted to get to.
And so over the last
year or so, we've
been working with
the Angular team
to get Angular2
Dart out the door.
I'm happy to say that
AngularDart 2.0 is launching
today.
And this is a
really nice system.
[APPLAUSE]
So, you'll be hearing more
about this in just a few minutes
from Ferhat and Matan.
But the nice things about
this is, it's idiomatic Dart.
So there is no more JavaScript
legacy in AngularDart 2.0.
this is all Dart,
in Dart, for Dart.
It's getting faster and faster.
In the last couple
months I think
we've seen a 10% speed
increase and I know,
Ferhat promises me that
there's more on the table.
An amazing thing, by moving it
into Dart, and really making it
focused on how does thing work
when compiled to Dart to JS
Is that it's gotten 40% smaller
JS output just in the last four
months.
So I figure if we do this
for another year or so we--
KASPER LUND: Should be good.
DAN GROVE: Should
be pretty good.
And this is used heavily today.
So all these things that we're
talking about like AdWords,
AdSense, Google Fiber.
They're all using this.
This is the core of
Google's ads tech stack
and it is in critical,
critical in the sense,
I like getting paid, use today.
So this is really,
really important.
KASPER LUND: It's been in
production for a while.
DAN GROVE: A number of
quarters at this point.
But even that wasn't
really enough.
People wanted to know where
their components were,
because even if you give them
Angular, even if you give them
this great language, you give
them these nice libraries,
people still want more.
They want to not write
their own components.
And well guess what, we
created a ton of components
as we build all
these applications.
And these components are shared
across many of our applications
within Google.
And we're launching
a preview today
of AngularDart components.
These are material
design components
that you can use in
your application.
Their industrial strength,
they work cross-browser,
they're really nicely done.
There's an actual
UI team that works
on making sure that these comply
with the material design spec.
So you can start using these
and playing with them now.
So overall, we finally
feel like we've
got a really great web stack.
So we've got the language,
we got the core libraries,
we got the ecosystem.
Which many of you all
have contributed to.
And I think things like
getting pub.dartlang.org.
Out early so that we had a
coherent place to share stuff,
was wonderful for the ecosystem.
We've got a great framework.
We've got components.
We've got the full web stack.
And now we feel really
ready for the future.
We made it really easy to
use JavaScript libraries.
We've got these
incredibly fast dev
cycles using the dev compiler.
Scalability that's
incredible, really
for best in class
kind of scalability.
And we've made it really easy
to build high performance UIs.
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
But I mean this is a
really nice future.
But it's not the entire future.
There's a whole other set of
things that we could be doing,
and that we are doing,
that I want to give you
a sneak preview into.
But to make sure
that it actually
is something that will
interest you guys,
I started looking at
what kind of things
were popular at the last summit.
And there was one
talk that was just
way more popular
than anything else.
DAN GROVE: That was
my talk, that right?
KASPER LUND: That
was not your talk.
[LAUGHTER]
It was not my talk either.
Most of it was fairly popular,
but this one, this one talk
here, had like 50% of
all views on YouTube
of these presentations
in one single talk.
And the talk was about Dart
code for mobile devices.
It's called Sky: An Experiment
Writing Dart for Mobile.
And it showed
something kind of neat.
It showed you a way to
write Dart code that
ended up on a mobile device.
In this case, like showing a
spinning cube on a real phone.
And in some ways,
it's a bit surprising
that you get that many views
on a video presentation that
shows you a spinning
cube on a device.
So I wonder, why
is that so popular.
Are you guys really so
impressed with spinning cubes?
[LAUGHTER]
Some people are saying yes.
That's kind of neat.
I think the reason why you
guys are excited about this,
and the reason why I'm
excited about this,
is it holds promise.
It shows you that there
might be a way in the future
where you can write
for Android and iOS,
build a really high performance,
really slick mobile apps,
for both kinds of devices from a
single codebase, based on Dart.
I think that kind of
promise is really exciting.
Maybe as importantly
though, it also
showed you a way to
write mobile apps
in a way that was very
pleasant and approachable.
I think the native stacks out
there today are really useful,
and you can write
wonderful things with that.
But I think there
is something to be
said for a more pleasant,
more delightful experience.
Something that's much
easier to get started on.
And what Eric
showed you last year
was just much easier
to get going with.
You'd type in the Dart
code, you hit a button,
and you have it on the device.
It's really simple,
slick, and I think
that sort of got you
guys excited about what
we could do with that.
So this was basically the
talk from 1 and 1/2 years ago.
And things have
happened since then.
It was called Sky back in the
day, now it's called Flutter.
It has a new spiffy logo.
But this is not the
most interesting thing
that's happened.
We've actually gone
from spinning cubes,
to being able to have
real, modern, beautiful UIs
on Android and iOS from
the same source base.
And I think my main
point with this,
is that you do not want to be
late for the keynote tomorrow.
So tomorrow we're going to
spend a lot of time on mobile.
Starting with the
keynote and then
diving into the
Dart technologies
that power Dart for
mobile and Flutter.
So I think tomorrow will prove
to be another exciting day
at the summit.
So I think mobile is
clearly an area for us that
excites you, and excites us, and
something we are investing in
very heavily.
It's a very exciting
part of our future.
But I think the main
takeaway for you
guys here is that, Dart
is doing really well.
We have a very productive Stack.
We're growing really fast.
Anders mentioned that Dart is
the fastest growing language
at Google.
That's really significant.
Furthermore, maybe
that's one thing that
makes us really proud here,
is that Dart actually powers
Google's most critical apps.
Like the $70 billion
US dollars, I almost
want to impersonate Dr.
Evil when I see that number.
DAN GROVE: Yeah no kidding.
KASPER LUND: This is really
almost too big numbers right,
but it's kind of interesting
for us to be part of that.
It's really significant.
And maybe for you guys,
even more importantly,
it's ready for you.
You can actually start
using the same stack,
and use the fact that we
have a full Dart web stack.
[APPLAUSE]